[Musique]
euh
donc
[Musique] [Musique
]
étrangère
[Musique]
actuellement je pense qu'il y aurait euh
et il y a effectivement
un débat sur le déplacement des vestiges archéologiques
et leur décontextualisation euh et donc
on est l'argument de la
décontextualisation
et puis  l'autre argument est pour
la sécurité des artefacts
et je dois dire que le granit va
probablement très bien se débrouiller,
mais les sphinx sont en
grès
et sont une pierre plus sensible,
d'autant plus
que le climat change et qu'il
pleut plus fréquemment que  le caire
et il y a beaucoup de trafic et de
pollution, donc je pense que
ce n'est pas la meilleure pratique des antiquités
en termes
[musique]
à tahrir en 2011 où les gens non seulement se
sont assis ensemble mais ils ont conversé entre
eux ils
ont eu des réunions ils ont eu
des discussions significatives ils  aussi dansé
et chanté et mis des pancartes et que c'est
quelque chose d'aussi simple que c'est
profondément
subversif en ce qui
concerne l'état égyptien et je pense que ce que
nous voyons maintenant
est une décision délibérée concertée et très
consciente  de la part de
l'État
pour empêcher que cela ne se reproduise,
c'est une tentative délibérée de
dire que l'État que ce qui s'est passé en
2011 était une erreur,
nous pouvons facilement en effacer toute trace
de la
mémoire publique et nous transformons le
carré en quelque chose  sinon
[Musique]
toi